>> Jesse: THANKS TO BIDEN'S
BOTCHED EXIT FROM AFGHANISTAN WE
ARE NOT ONLY LEAVING BEHIND
AMERICANS BUT MILITARY WEAPONS
FOR THE TALIBAN.
JOE BIDEN SET OUR ENEMY UP
PRETTY NICELY.
THEY INHERITED BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF GUNS, WAR VEHICLES AND
AIRCRAFT.
REPORTS SAY THAT THE TALIBAN NOW
HAS MORE BLACK HAWK HELICOPTERS
THAN 85% OF COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD.
IT WASN'T LONG AGO THAT
DEMOCRATS TRIED TO IMPEACH TRUMP
FOR PAUSING MILITARY AIDE TO AN
ALLY.
BIDEN HANDED ALL THERE WAS
MILITARY AIDE OVER TO AN ENEMY.
SOMETHING HE MUST HAVE LEARNED
FROM BARACK OBAMA.
HE GAVE MEXICAN CARTELS GUNS
THAT KILLED AMERICANS.
AND NOW UNCLE JOE IS GIVING
PEOPLE WE FOUGHT FOR 20 YEARS TO
RIVAL THE BEST IN THE WORLD.
JOINING ME IS ANDREW FROM OPEN
THE BOOKS.COM.
I READ YOUR REPORT.
HERE'S HOW I KNOW THE AFGHAN
ARMY WAS A JOKE.
THE U.S. MILITARY GAVE THE
AFGHAN ARMY 174 MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF DRONES AND THEY LOST
THEM.
>> EVEN IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR 2022, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT THEY WERE
DOING SUCH A GOOD JOB IN
AFGHANISTAN THEIR PLAN WAS GOING
TO WORK OUT SO WELL, THEY DIDN'T
CUT SPENDING TO THE AFGHAN
MILITARY IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET,
THEY INCREASED IT.
THERE WAS GOING TO BE NO
TAXPAYER SAVING.
THEY TOOK THE AFGHANISTAN
SECURITY BUDGET FROM $3 BILLION
TO 3.3-BILLION DOLLARS.
AFTER LOSING THOSE DRONES THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS GOING
TO PROVIDE THE AFGHAN SECURITY
ANOTHER 22 MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF DRONES.
>> Jesse: THE DEFENSE
CONTRACTORS STILL CENTER TO GET
PAID.
YOU CAN'T STOP THE GRAVY TRAIN.
THEY NEED THE MONEY.
WE LEFT THE TALIBAN WITH
BLACKHAWKS ATTACK HELICOPTERS
AND AIRPLANES WITH HELLFIRE
MISSILES.
LET'S SAY THEY FIND PILOTS THAT
IT ARE WORTH THEIR, YOU KNOW --
IF THEY CAN'T, THEY CAN SELL
THESE THINGS FOR PARTS TO THE
CHINESE OR PAKISTAN.
>> THE TALIBAN WILL SELL TICKETS
TO THEIR GUN SHOW.
THERE ARE 18 SURVEILLANCE
AIRPLANES THAT OUR AUDITORS
IDENTIFIED GIVEN TO THE AFGHAN
SECURITY FORCES.
THE TALIBAN CONTROL THOSE NOW.
THIS IS AN AMERICAN MILITARY
SECURITY PROBLEM.
THE CHINESE AND THE RUSSIANS
WANT ACCESS TO THOSE SECRETS.
TODAY AMERICA IS LESS SAFE THAN
WE WERE JUST 30 DAYS AGO.
>> Jesse: CHINA WILL REVERSE NEW
JERSEY ALL OF THE TECHNOLOGY.
-- ENGINEER ALL OF THE
TECHNOLOGY.
IF WE HAVE TO GO BACK IN WITH
SEARCH AND RESCUE FOR STRANDED
AMERICANS OR SEARCH AND DESTROY
FOR ISIS-K, WE WILL HAVE TO FACE
GRENADE LAUNCHES AND NIGHT
VISION SNIPER RIFLE SCOPES.
THESE ARE NOT CHEAP.
THEY ARE EFFECTIVE.
WE WILL LOOSE OUR NIGHT TIME
DOMINANCE.
IT'S A HUGE SCANTSAL.
WE WILL PAY A PRICE.
>> 600,000 WEAPONS THAT THE
TALIBAN CONTROLS.DALAL.
WE WILL PAY A PRICE.
>> 600,000 WEAPONS THAT THE
TALIBAN CONTROLS.
THE RIFLES NOBODY KNOWS WHERE IN
COUNTRY THAT IS.
THE TALIBAN CONTROL WEAPONS.
35,000 GRENADE LAUNCHES AND
2,600 MORTARS.
THE HOWITSER IS TAKE OUT
A BRIDGE, BUILDING OR AN AIRPORT
RUNWAY.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE NOT WRAPPED
OUR HEAD AROUND HOW HORRIBLE
THIS AFGHANISTAN DISASTER IT.
IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE.
>> HERE'S ONE REASON WHY.
>> Jesse: I DO HAVE TO RUN.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
COVER THIS UP.
THAT'S WHY REPUBLICANS NEED TO
TAKE T